on va peser le compost une fois par mois
depuis octobre
marie carpentier ses filles pèsent leurs
déchets le contenu du bac de recyclage
la poubelle le compost tout y passe
donc ces trois lettres la famille fait
partie des cinquante foyers de rosemont
la petite patrie qui se sont engagés à
participer au défi zéro déchet mis sur
pied par l'arrondissement
j'ai fait de faire plein d'actions
américains qui viennent pour réduire
l'empreinte écologique
cela veut dire entre autres à porter ses
propres contenants à l'épicerie pour
éviter les emballages et gérer sa
consommation nourriture pour abolir le
gaspillage alimentaire
on a comme commencé à acheter en vrac
certains aliments comme par exemple les
flocons d'avoine lui le dos les bons
recteur la vieille bouteille puis on l'a
remplie ce mode de vie peut paraître
inatteignable pour certains pour que ce
soit pas contraignant il faut y aller un
pas à la fois c'est sûr que si on décide
de changer toutes ses habitudes du jour
au lendemain ça va devenir un vrai défi
petit à petit la famille de marie
carpentier repenser la façon de
consommer est ce que je peux faire autre
chose avec l'objet que je vais mettre
dans la poubelle est ce que je peux lui
donner une seconde vie
c'est ainsi qu'elle a décidé de faire
réparer une lampe défectueuse
plutôt que d'en acheter une neuve même
en cette période des fêtes la famille
limitera sa prédiction déchets moi ce
que j'ai opté pour cette année c'est
plus de frais des activités des choses
qui vont qui vont faire comment passer
du temps semble donc long qui nécessite
pas d'emballage et sylvia des cadeaux à
emballer quoi pas des vieux journaux d
des magazines des dessins d'enfants
réutiliser des choses qu'on a déjà si on
a reçu des sacs cadeaux que l'on peut
garder qu'on peut réutiliser le déficit
zéro déchets prendra fin en avril
elle espère que d'ici là leur nouveau
mode de vie sera bien ancrée dans leur
routine ici balle et michaela payne
radio canada montréal